[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres on se souvient tous de
l'algarade dans l'émission apostrophe
entre Serge Gainsbourg et Guy Béart
Serge Gainsbourg ayant eu le malheur de
dire que la chanson était un art mineur
ce qui avait révolté Guibert alors art
mineur art majeur toujours est-il que la
chanson jalonne nos existences nous y
accrochons nos souvenirs de jeunesse de
voyage de vacances d'amour elle
cristallise nos nostalgie et c'est de
chanson dont nous avons parlé ce soir
dans cette émission quand l'honneur de
Julien Clerc et détiennent rhodagy nous
avons intitulé si on chantait nous
allons parler de chansons mais nous
allons parler d'auteurs de compositeurs
d'interprètes et de producteurs et nous
allons le faire en permis de deux
invités en compagnie d'Yves Bigot en
soirée bonsoir Denis Yves vous êtes un
dirigeant de l'audiovisuel public à tête
de TV5 Monde mais avant cela vous étiez
à France Télévisions mais vous êtes
surtout aussi un grand journaliste
musical vous avez fait les grandes
heures d'Europe 1 vous avez été à Libé
vous vous écrivez des livres on vient de
republier d'ailleurs votre biographie de
Michel Berger mais ça n'est pas pour vos
œuvres que vous venez aujourd'hui c'est
pour philosophie de la chanson moderne
que de Bob Dylan qui est publié en
français aux éditions fayardes car vous
êtes l'un des grands connaisseurs de
l'oeuvre de Bob Dylan et je crois l'un
des seuls journalistes français qu'il
est interviewé et puis nous sommes en
compagnie aussi de Françoise kanetti
vous aussi vous avez eu une carrière
brillante à la tête d'une agence de
communication vous aviez créé et puis à
la tête des productions Jacques Canetti
et c'est de Jacques Canetti votre père
nous allons parler parce que vous lui
consacrez une biographie Brassens la
plaie Socrate
biographie
d'un homme
extraordinaire ou d'un homme qui a une
vie extraordinaire je le rappelle pour
mémoire il a dominé la chanson française
du début des années 50 à la fin des
années 60-12 années 70 il était à la
tête d'une salle très célèbre de
Montmartre qui s'appelait les Trois
Baudets il dirigeait les disques Philips
il était l'organisateur des tournées
canetty mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on
a rien dit si on ne précise pas qu'il a
découvert et lancer Edith Piaf Georges
Brassens Jacques Brel Félix Leclerc
Serge Gainsbourg Serge Reggiani en tant
que chanteur Higelin et tant d'autres
cette liste est complètement dingue
absolument mon père était un révélateur
de talent qui se promenait choisi avec
les oreilles grandes ouvertes et qui
n'avaient pas peur des artistes inconnus
il les recherchait et quand il
rencontrait par son métier des auteurs
compositeurs beaucoup d'auteurs
compositeurs interprètent ils savaient
déceler leur talent avec plusieurs
années d'avance tous ces gens avaient
une écriture qui avait beaucoup d'avance
sur leur temps donc ça ne marchait pas
tout de suite et donc mon père était là
allait soutenir à leur donner confiance
avec sa persévérance légendaire et ces
artistes arrivaient à éclore et
et mieux encore à marquer
leur génération et nos générations
alors si on reprend au départ il est né
en Bulgarie il perd son père très jeune
et il se retrouve avec sa mère et ses
deux frères et là ils vont pérégriner en
Europe Angleterre Autriche Allemagne
Suisse finalement il s'installe à Paris
quand je dis ces deux frères c'est pas
n'importe qui parce que son frère est né
c'est Elias kaneki qui va devenir prix
Nobel de littérature et son autre frère
c'est Georges Canetti qui a été fauché
trop jeune par la tuberculose mais qui
était un grand chercheur de l'Institut
Pasteur qui a inventé un médecin qui a
inventé la trithérapie et qui aurait
probablement été reçu de grandes de
grands honneurs s'il avait vécu plus
longtemps c'est quoi le secret de leur
mère Mathilde pour arriver à faire trois
enfants qui étaient intelligents
cultivé et qui avait le goût de la
réussite c'est que c'était quoi sa
recette magique
ma grand-mère Mathilde c'était une femme
absolument extraordinaire elle devient
veuve à l'âge de 27 ans et elle éduque
ses enfants avec trois mots clés
enthousiastes confiant et organisation
et elle leur dit toujours réussir dans
la vie les enfants c'est pas gagné de
l'argent c'est apporter à son siècle
quelque chose de différent
donc elle met la barre
et ils se sont payés à ça et je crois
qu'ils se sont pliait à ça en tous les
cas tous les trois ont eu des destins
absolument extraordinaires et ils ont
rendu hommage à leur mère dans tous les
cas alors avant guère votre père
commence à travailler à la radio avec le
chien blanche et dans les disques et
puis pendant la guerre il crée en
Afrique du Nord des tournées musicales
et c'est au lendemain de la guerre à la
Libération que commence vraiment son
envol je l'ai dit il crée les trois
boudets il dirige des disques il fait
des tournées mais c'est plus que ça en
fait c'est assez frappant quand dans
votre livre les trois bodets et puis la
maison de campagne de votre père et puis
le petit village des Pyrénées où il
accuse c'est une bande c'est un groupe
c'est un club c'est un club d'affinité
dans lequel Brel discute avec Pierre Dac
et de Vaux avec Brassens autour de votre
père c'est pas simplement des individus
pas un moment un groupe une bande un
club final chimie en fait c'est une
alchimie de talent qui n'ont pas encore
été révélés Brassens sous Brel mettre
quand même beaucoup de temps à réussir
pas Gainsbourg Guy Béart qu'on a pas
cité mais que j'aimerais citer il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui vont vivre
comme ça dans cette espèce de pépinière
de talent qui est les Trois Baudets et
dans cette pépinière de talent mon père
donne le temps nécessaire à un artiste
pour éclore pour éclore d'une part et
donne aussi le temps nécessaire au
public pour être préparé à découvrir une
autre langue d'autres sujets d'autres
chansons c'est l'apparition de ces
fameux chanteurs à guitares dont on
parle c'est-à-dire c'est la naissance
l'émergence des auteurs compositeurs
interprètent avec des chansons qui
choquent Brassens choc à ses débuts Brel
en parlant pas Boris Vian Boris Vian ce
sont même des gens qui sont interdit
d'antenne
plusieurs portraits de Guy Béart de
Félix Leclerc j'ai été frappé par parce
qu'il y a deux êtres qui sont très
proches de votre père et dont le
portrait est incroyablement contrasté
c'est Brassens le généreux et Brel le
ténébreux
Brassens le généreux le bienveillant
l'ami l'ami la fidélité la fidélité en
amitié et puis Brel qui est Monsieur
casse-cou c'est-à-dire
Brel n'aime pas les chemins tout tracés
bref ne veut pas s'ennuyer Brel brel
chante hurle
devient si vous voulez devient
l'interprète de ces chansons et c'est un
interprète magnifique mais il est très
dur notamment avec votre père parce que
dans ce livre on voit qu'il y a des
grandes histoires de d'amitié des grands
coups de foudre amicaux mais aussi
d'énormes brouilles parce que ces
artistes ne sont pas faciles mais parce
que votre père ne devait pas être facile
non plus mais non mais ils sont pas
faciles ni les uns ni les autres ne sont
faciles ce sont des gens qui sont à
l'écoute qui sont
ce sont des gens qui ont des points de
vue et
Brel enfin je parle non pas d'une
brouille mais je parle d'une
conversation sur la reconnaissance entre
Brel
Brel dit à mon père en substance
vous me demandez qu'elle est ici si je
dois vous être reconnaissant mais pas du
tout je ne vous suis pas reconnaissant
en ayant réussi tel que j'ai réussi j'ai
rendu j'ai fait au mage à votre
Talenti je le connaissais pas
personnellement et je connais évidemment
tout son travail puisque j'ai dirigé
bien longtemps après la maison de
disques qui s'appelait Mercury donc et
donc le patrimoine de tous ces artistes
formidables qu'il avait découvert il y a
des développer mais c'est pas si
fréquent au fond parce que les
producteurs sont plutôt cachés derrière
les artistes c'est pas si fréquent il
fallait vraiment que votre père est un
incroyable talent pour que sa mémoire
perdure pour qu'on se souvienne de lui
il a quand même marqué incroyablement
son temps et d'ailleurs on se demande
mais quel était le secret de de Jacques
Canetti pour qu'il ait eu à ce point une
empreinte sur la chanson française
pendant deux décennies c'est l'envie je
crois que c'est l'envie l'envie de faire
partager ses enthousiasme mon père est
un
indéfectible enthousiaste c'est-à-dire
c'est quelqu'un qui lorsqu'il écoute
quelqu'un lorsqu'il voit quelque chose
il a ce coup de foudre par exemple pour
la pour l'architecture de Le Corbusier
nous avons vécu très longtemps dans une
maison Le Corbusier parce que mon père a
été le premier occupant d'un appartement
Le Corbusier donc si vous voulez il a
des il a des intuitions qui l'écoutent
qu'il écoute il a des envies qu'il a
suivi et il a envie d'aider les gens à
se à ce à se révéler et si vous voulez
il y a aussi autre chose c'est qu'il a
une vision du public
qui est le plus pour mon père le public
est intelligent
on ne donne pas n'importe quoi au public
et donc il a des critères de qualité
qu'il veut faire partager je crois que
là c'est un secret parce que parce que
tous les artistes qu'il a aimé dans sa
vie que ce soit Édith Piaf Jeanne Moreau
Brassens Brel Gainsbourg Reggiani
Brigitte Fontaine sont des gens
totalement différents mais qui ont des
textes ciselés magnifiques qui font
attention qui ont des valeurs dans leur
texte qui ont une certaine qui ont qui
ont beaucoup d'humour et qui sont
férocement tendre aussi
et puis il a cette dimension
révolutionnaire quoi vous dites Le
Corbusier il aime il aime le nouveau il
aime la rupture il aime l'avant-garde il
aime le ski ce qui n'est pas il n'est
pas il est pas il est pas conventionnel
du tout pas du tout il n'a pas peur de
l'inconnu
Brassens la plaie Socrate c'est un très
joli livre très joli portrait d'un homme
vraiment hors du commun et entouré de
géants et au-delà de lui au-delà de ces
artistes c'est le portrait d'un milieu
un peu comme Lazares
constituait un milieu et d'une époque
qui a malheureusement disparu mais que
vous faites revivre avec beaucoup de
talents alors puisqu'on parle de géant
c'est une bonne transition parce qu'on
publie en France philosophie de la
traduction de philosophie de la chanson
moderne de Bob Dylan aux éditions
fayards est-ce qu'on a besoin de
présenter Bob Dylan je crois qu'on
connaît tous des dizaines de chansons
Miss timberine man blowin de Win i want
you
like a rolling Stone mais Dylan n'est
pas simplement ce fantastique auteur
compositeur interprète il est peintre et
il est chez moi du peu prix Nobel de
littérature
alors Yves ce livre est assez inattendu
parce qu'on avait lu il y a quelques
années chroniques 1 qui était un livre
plutôt autobiographique et là c'est une
soixantaine de disques de chansons sur
lesquelles il écrit deux trois pages de
d'associations d'interprétations souvent
érudites mais très peu de dimensions
autobiographiques c'est un livre c'est
un objet non identif alors totalement
oui personne n'a jamais écrit de livres
de de ce type alors
pas autobiographique
je suis pas si sûr parce que je pense
que justement il glisse mais c'est
extrêmement dilanesque puisque c'est un
adjectif en anglais qui est validé
de justement dire des choses très
personnelles et très profondes en ayant
l'impression surtout de ne pas en parler
mais ça ça fait partie de tous les
différents masques derrière lesquels il
se cache moi je pense qu'il s'est jamais
autant révélé justement que dans ce
livre parce que dans dans ces chroniques
qui avaient quand même eu le puzzer au
passage
justement il mettait beaucoup de masques
et il y a beaucoup de choses dans ces
chroniques qui sont passionnantes à lire
mais qui sont une vérité mais pas une
vérité journalistique c'est à dire que
en fait il arrange beaucoup de choses il
les réécrit etc alors que là en fait je
pense que dans ces donc c'est
commentaires en fait assez socratique
euh justement de de ces 6 66 chansons
qu'il a décidé comme ça de d'examiner en
fait ils glissent des choses très très
personnelles sur les choses qui
évidemment est en lui-même un auteur et
un compositeur et un interprète et un
certain Bank
il vit et il connaît moins je pense
qu'il s'est en fait jamais autant révélé
que dans ce livre là alors en tout cas
ceux qu'on ce qu'on voit bien ce sont
ces inspirations parce que sur ces 66
chansons c'est d'ailleurs surprenant moi
je m'attendais à ce qui est beaucoup
plus de chansons de folk il y a je crois
une chanson de PET see girls mais il y a
pas Audi Gautry enfin en revanche il y a
une écrasante représentation de la
country un peu de rock un peu de rythm
and blues un peu de Saül mais c'est
vraiment la country qui est au cœur de
son inspiration parce que la country
music c'est l'équivalent de ce que
Jacques Canetti à à découvert et a
permis de
promouvoir en France c'est là qui est
l'écriture de la chanson américaine en
tous les cas dans les années 40 dans les
années 50 avant que Dylan justement
n'invente un nouveau job qui est celui
qui l'incarne celui qui faisait dire qui
lui faisait dire Léonard à Léonard Cohen
toi tu es le numéro 1 mais moi je suis
la matrice et alors et ce physique
je sais plus il est incroyablement
enraciné dans la musique blanche
américaine la plus profonde totalement
mais noir aussi même s'ils ne le dit pas
autant alors il faut bien comprendre une
chose c'est 66 chansons c'est pas c'est
66 chansons préférées c'est pas les 66
chansons qui l'ont le plus inspiré c'est
celle qui lui permettent de commenter ce
qu'il pense de
l'importance et de l'histoire de la
musique et de la chanson américaine donc
déjà c'est assez biaisé et puis il faut
bien comprendre le titre aussi alors
philosophie oui car en réalité il y a
une philosophie globale contrairement à
ce qu'affirme le New Yorker d'ailleurs
qui dit c'est un titre qui nous enduit
en erreur pas du tout parce qu'en fait
ce qu'il cherche à démontrer dans ce
livre donc ça philosophie c'est que des
paroles
sur de la musique des syllabes sur des
notes
c'est l'exemple
ultime de 1 + 1 = 3 donc de la magie en
fait qui est celle de la chanson et puis
pardon de Nîmes quand il dit la chanson
moderne évidemment tout le monde dit ah
mais comment ça se fait qu'il parle pas
de ses contemporains de ces héritiers
non plus ou des rappeurs d'aujourd'hui
c'est parce que pour lui la chanson
moderne c'est exactement
ce qu'a développé Jacques Canetti en
France c'est à partir du moment où la
chanson a des auteurs et où on n'est
plus dans la tradition venue des balades
anglo irlandais chanson des années 45
ans en fait c'est ça qui est exactement
ça c'est des temps modernes de Charlie
Chaplin en fait c'est parce qu'en effet
cette modernité là à la calice aurait
fait c'est pas celle d'aujourd'hui en
effet on est frappé c'est c'est alors il
y a très peu de de grands chanteurs il y
en a un peu la Little Richard et Elvis
Presley et Bing Crosby mais ils sont une
quinzaine et et d'ailleurs souvent ce
sont plutôt des phases B que des
chansons il y a tout petit fruit mais ce
sont plutôt des phases mais c'est vrai
que c'est c'est les chanteurs qu'il aime
enfin c'est la chanson des mâles blancs
de plus de 80 ans et il y a il y a tout
de nous il y a peu de et c'est c'est
prédécesseurs il y a très peu de ses
contemporains bien sûr et alors en
revanche qui est extrêmement intéressant
amusant et pour moi une découverte c'est
que
l'étendue le compas de sa curiosité et
parfois de son érudition il fait des
associations entre Nina Simone et
L'Étranger de Camus ou entre telle
chanson et la peinture enfin il a il a
il a un horizon de curiosité qui est
complètement incroyable c'est le maître
de l'interte textualité c'est à dire
qu'il est capable de vous amalgamer des
choses dont on a pas idée puis avec un
style qui est qui est inouï moi j'admire
le traducteur parce que aller
du Dylan qui en plus utilisent beaucoup
de vernaculaires c'est voilà c'est c'est
coton mais c'est surtout aussi ce qu'il
cherche je suppose à démontrer c'est la
magie incroyable de la chanson et de
cette musique et de la musique
américaine qui a quelque chose de
beaucoup plus musical pardon que ne
l'aura jamais la chanson française
pourquoi parce qu'il y a cette base
afro-américaine qui est au fond qui est
derrière qui porte des choses qui
portent une une émotion presque une
émotivité qui est qui est toujours
sous-jacente parce qu'il y a du blues
derrière tout ça
derrière et puis surtout voilà il
cherche à montrer combien en fait
vous l'avez un peu dans votre
introduction de ni
annoncé
c'est que c'est la chose qui touche le
plus intimement le plus profondément la
chanson on dit vous savez que quand les
gens vont s'éteindre la dernière chose
qui conserve de mémoire c'est un refrain
c'est un air c'est une chanson donc ça
montre combien en fait la chanson nous
nous pénètre beaucoup plus profondément
que tout autre forme d'art et dans ces
associations ces livres associations
c'est digressions on voit que la chanson
recueille le monde recueille le monde
des sentiments le monde de l'art mais
quel portrait vous diriez que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que c'était un livre
assez intime et personnel
quel portrait vous vous semble-t-il
n'est de la lecture de moi j'ai eu
l'impression d'un d'un je ne connais pas
je ne connais j'adore ces chansons que
je connais toutes ces chansons mais
presque un asperger enfin quelqu'un
d'extrêmement à la fois ouvert sur le
monde par une forme d'hypersensibilité
mais très fermée froid par moment enfin
drôle de personnage un personnage
biblique
je pense que lui se voit comme ça en
fait comme quelqu'un qui a une mission
qui d'une certaine façon est un
représentant dans l'espèce humaine et
qui
incarne quelque chose d'ailleurs je
pense que le jeune Robert Zimmerman
savait qu'il était Bob Dylan déjà et il
a cette espèce d'incroyable altérité une
singularité c'est un homme totalement
mystérieux alors si vous lui demandez de
vous passer le sel il va vous passer le
sel donc c'est à la fois quelqu'un qui
est très simple et direct dans la vie
mais qui ne supporte pas par exemple
qu'on lui pose des questions donc ça
rend pas la vie des interviews
nécessairement facile mais oui c'est
c'est un être totalement mystérieux
totalement singulier
voilà Bob Dylan philosophie de la
chanson moderne je recommande vivement
de lire ce livre en écoutant les
chansons parce que tout à coup il y en a
beaucoup que je ne connaissais pas c'est
à dire si vous vous dites ça vous
imaginez moi et non mais il est
tellement spécialiste justement il
connaisseur de ça et c'est ça aussi qui
veut un peu démontrer c'est venez pas me
raconter d'histoires j'en sais plus ce
que vous mais il y a des morceaux qui
ont jamais été publiés par exemple dont
il parle on dit d'ailleurs qu'il est le
chanteur américain qui connaît par cœur
le plus de chansons du répertoire
musical américain mais alors ces
musiciens disent que Dylan il entend une
chanson une fois et il est capable de la
rechanter 10 ans plus tard il a mémorisé
les accords les harmonies et la totalité
des paroles je pense que Jacques Canetti
aurait adoré s'occuper de Bob Dylan
alors vous savez que Brassens avait ça
ils connaissait toutes les chansons du
répertoire il les connaissait par cœur
il savait les jouer ils les chantaient
avant de chanter
le bonheur des livres c'est d'abord le
plaisir de ses lecteurs et nous allons
écouter
l'intervention de l'un d'entre eux qui
va vous poser une question je crois à
vous Françoise
[Musique]
bonjour Denis bonjour Françoise Canetti
je suis David le bourre étudiant en 3ème
année de licence de lettres à
l'Université d'Orléans professeur
stagiaire de français et logiquement
passionné de littérature la littérature
c'est un monde par lequel je suis entré
à travers la musique
en étudiant des textes comme ceux de
dinos Jacques Brel alpha one entre
autres parce que j'y trouve la
conjugaison de l'encrier et des cordes
vocales la dernière lecture c'est le
jeune homme Dani Arnault le dernier prix
Nobel de littérature donc c'est un
ouvrage très court rédigé dans la langue
d'Asnières c'est littérature qui hérite
en quelque sorte de la simplicité
poétique d'une chanson
Françoise kanetti c'est tout le monde de
la musique que l'on voit croître à
travers la vie de votre le père et selon
moi la littérature c'est la
transposition des harmonies et des
discordances c une symphonie sur papier
historiquement la musique a toujours
chanté la littérature on a chanté
Jacques Prévert on a chanté Raymond
Queneau vous l'abordez d'ailleurs dans
votre ouvrage ma question c'est donc
pensez-vous que la littérature puisse
écrire la fantaisie impromptue de la
musique
question complexe de David et cher
François il faudrait reformuler
pensez-vous que la musique
puisse je le comprends comme étant
est-ce que la musique est capable de
reproduire
ce que donne la littérature ou plutôt
est-ce que la littérature est capable de
reproduire ce que donne la musique moi
je dis non
moi je ne sais pas mais en tous les cas
dans le dans la dans la forme que je
connais dans la forme dans laquelle j'ai
été élevée de la chanson je vois qu'il y
a cette alchimie entre la musique et les
paroles et la musique et le texte qui
sont indiscociables c'est-à-dire une
bonne chanson c'est cette enfin une
œuvre d'art finalement une œuvre une
chanson c'est quoi 2 minutes 30 de
bonheur qui vous raconte une histoire
qui est universelle et qui traverse les
générations voilà ben c'est c'est moi
c'est ce que je connais et c'est dans ça
que j'ai été élevé et c'est cette
alchimie merveilleuse
voilà que je recommande à tous les gens
qui nous ramène au débat que j'évoquais
entre Guy Béart que vous aimez beaucoup
et donc manifester l'intelligence et
Serge Gainsbourg que vous aimez beaucoup
aussi est-ce que la musique la chanson
est un art mineur ou un art majeur je
crois que vous savez pourquoi il s'en
voulait autant l'un l'autre c'est parce
que Guy Béart au début des années 60
avait dénoncé Gainsbourg à sur les
plagiats des musiques de l'album
Gainsbourg percussion c'est pour ça que
Gainsbourg vous pouvez pas le blairer
cette émission est quasiment terminée
mais avant que nous nous quittions il
faut que vous recommandiez que vous nous
donniez le coup de cœur de cette semaine
et attention c'est satisfait ou
remboursé il faut que nos ceux qui nous
ont suivis et qui vont suivre vos
recommandations soit pleinement heureux
de la lecture que vous allez leur
proposer on va commencer par Yves quel
est le livre que vous nous recommandez
alors le seul livre qui de près ou de
loin ressemble à la philosophie de la
chanson moderne de Bob Dylan mais en
français c'est déjàment sur l'herbe de
Guillaume Durand qui a reçu le Prix
Renaudot de l'essai et que je
rembourserai à celui de vos
téléspectateurs qui l'achèteraient qui
lancerait pas satisfait sachez qu'il a
fait l'objet d'une émission ici et Cher
Françoise quel est le livre que vous
recommandez je vois que vous en avez
plus 15 qui n'est pas la règle ce qui
est pas la règle mais je vous en supplie
je recommande le dernier livre de Serge
regani beauté j'écris ton nom Serge race
banni comme comme Bob Dylan et peintre
et peintre avant d'être écrivain auteur
de toutes ces magnifiques chansons que
Jeanne Moreau a chanté et ce que j'ai
aimé dans cet ouvrage c'est justement
que risque vanille décrit son métier de
peintre sa relation avec avec les
marchands ça son enfant enfin sa
jeunesse et puis bien sûr sa rencontre
avec sa femme Lula qu'il va qu'il va
aimer pendant 50 ans et qui va donner
une littérature et des chansons
absolument magnifiques
magnifique je vous arrête là parce qu'il
faut que nous proposions aussi les
livres que nous avons que nous avons
choisi je peux pas vous parler de mon
cité son nom de mon disque de chevet
c'est Dominique A c'est Dominique A qui
a fait un disque absolument magnifique
et qui vient de publier son premier
livre de poésie voilà très bien nous
nous sommes restés dans le thème de
l'émission avec Patti Smith ce sont ses
souvenirs de l'année du singe qui était
la neige je crois où elle est après le
covid où elle raconte où elle c'est un
mélange de souvenirs elle perd des amis
c'est une longue méditation sur la vie
très belle d'ailleurs de ça me Shepard
la mort de sa maison
Leonard Cohen c'est difficile de parler
de Dylan sans parler Leonard Cohen ils
font comme un couple au fond
et ça c'est une biographie de Pascal
boisiz
Elvis bertrandical excellence
journaliste musical très faces depuis à
Lescure tout Véronique Sanson album par
album Véronique Sanson peut-être qu'il
ne sera pas d'accord avec moi mais si
d'ailleurs et probablement l'une des
auteurs compositrices l'autrice
compositrice interprète les plus
talentueuses de la chanson François
Denis
et pas assez vanté
ces textes sont magnifiques ces chansons
sont belles et c'est un personnage hors
norme dont la vie est très romanesque
mais dont l'oeuvre restera j'en suis
certain pour de nombreuses décennies
voilà merci à vous deux merci pour
Françoise pour cette biographie merci
Yves d'avoir commenté avec votre science
et Bob Dylan qu'il faut remercier alors
je rappelle que votre biographie de
Michel Berger réactualisé étant
librairie cette émission est donc
terminée vous pouvez la revoir sur le
site de Public Sénat ou sur vos
plateformes préférées et puis nous nous
retrouvons la semaine prochaine
sauf si d'ici là nous sommes croisés
dans une librairie merci et bonsoir
[Musique]